JEN PERSON: Modern
businesses need
to manage not only the
identities of their employees,
but also the identities
of customers, partners,
and things.
Find out how to manage customers
in this episode of "Who's
There?"
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "Who's
There," a show where
we explore Cloud Identity.
Today, I am talking
about the app management
facet of Cloud Identity, which
is called Identity Platform.
Identity Platform
lets you manage
the identities of customers,
partners, and things
through a single service.
It adds Google grade identity
and access management
functionality to your
apps and services.
With Identity Platform, you
can add a widely adopted, user
friendly, and customizable
authentication
service to your web and
mobile apps with ease,
so you can focus on building
your app or service.
It supports multiple
authentication methods,
including SAML, OIDC,
email/password, social, phone,
and custom auth, to provide
flexible integration options
for any identity solution.
You can access Cloud
Identity through a range
of app SDKs for
Android, iOS, and web,
as well as server side Admin
SDKs for no Node.js, Java,
Python, and more.
To get your app up and
running even faster,
Identity Platform
provides a drop in,
customizable authentication
service for user sign
up and sign in.
When Google Cloud built
Identity Platform,
we wanted to meet the demands
of virtually any app or service.
That's why it's built on
Google Cloud's global scale
performance network
and security.
And it comes with an enterprise
grade support and SLA.
You can secure user accounts
and scale with confidence
as it protects your app's users,
and prevents account takeovers
by integrating with Google's
intelligence for account
protection.
OK, I think I've spent
enough time telling you why
Identity Platform is awesome.
Let's dive into how to configure
it for your Google project.
Before you get started, you need
to have a GCP project for which
you are a project
owner with billing
enabled for that project.
Once your project
is ready to go,
you can enable Identity Platform
from the GCP marketplace.
Go to the Identity
Platform marketplace
page in the GCP console.
Turn on Identity Platform
by clicking Enable Identity
Platform.
Next, navigate to
the GCP console.
You are now ready to start
using Identity Platform client
and Admin SDKs for
your apps and services.
After you enable
Identity Platform,
you can configure
authentication methods
so that your users can sign into
your applications and services.
I'll choose to
enable email/password
for this example.
Now you know how to get Identity
Platform up and running.
So what comes next?
You can use Identity
Platform client SDKs
for Android, iOS, and
web to allow end users
to authenticate your service.
You can also use it server
side with the Admin SDK
to migrate users or
customize user access level.
And there's a command line
option for migrating users
to Identity Platform.
To find out how to
complete these tasks
and more, check out the
documentation link below.
You can also check out
the Getting Started
videos for iOS,
Android, and web,
and then the Admin SDKs right
here on the Google Cloud
YouTube channel.
Thanks for watching
"Who's There."
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to be the first to know about
new episodes of the series.
[MUSIC PLAYING]